[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life and sex for a long time i'm rhett
and i'm link this week at the round
table of dim lighting we are continuing
to
press forward into our sexual
experiences
uh chronologically yeah
we try to fit the sex into sex timber
but we just have i mean we are just
exploding bursting
at the seams with so much sexual energy
that it has to spill
over into october so this is basically
part two of the purity culture you know
exploration specifically about college
yeah so uh episode three last week we
talked about
high school experience
this week let's let's get into the
college thing because that's when we
really got into all of the systemization
associated with purity culture it's kind
of here you're going to think you're
hearing like
i mean depending on your background i
think you might think you're listening
to two aliens speak i don't know i mean
you may have already felt that way but
it's gonna get even weirder today yeah i
mean we've we've lived it we've talked
about it amongst friends over the years
and we've alluded to especially when it
came to
uh
dating an engagement
with
with our wives in the book of
mythicality but we didn't really talk
about
the
the sex aspect of it so
we're gonna get into that today again i
i
i'm we're starting to see the responses
come in i'm excited that people are
resonating with the fact that hey we're
just speaking honestly about our
experience
and
that serves to remove some of the stigma
but it's it's still a bit awkward right
so
i i'm not going to ask you to sing
the theme song again thank you i didn't
want to it was really supposed to just
be a one time i'll give the disclaimer
if you don't want to hear
your two internet dads uncles brothers
cousins whatever you want to call us
talk
it specifically and
probably explicitly
about sex at times over the course of
this conversation maybe this isn't for
you so i'm just i'm just putting that
out there you don't have to listen to
this
but we're committed to
exploring it honestly and but we are
exploring it from
two very specific and narrow
perspectives so i guess you can you can
call this the non-musical disclaimer
that
we are two straight white cis male dudes
who
did not have sex until we were married
to our wives that we are still married
to we've each only had sex with one
woman
for over
20 years yeah and uh all of the
circumstances leading up to it that
we'll talk about today uh
are are very specific to our experience
and where and we acknowledge that
there's
a myriad
of experiences out there perspectives
and uh even the way that people interact
with purity culture there's a as i said
there's this
a broad spectrum of ways that
you can be impacted by that right
and some are really horrible some people
might say it was positive and
um
we're somewhere in the middle and i
think we can we'll explore that and
because i've seen a few of the
of the comments and people asking us to
talk about specific
things uh like are you guys going to
address you know sexual abuse as an
example i i want to be clear and say
that we are speaking from our experience
and our perspective so this is not
comprehensive it's not an exhaustive
exploration of everything that we think
about sex
we're not going to talk about sexual
abuse
because that's not something that we
personally have experienced and if we're
going to start talking about that we
would bring someone in who has a
perspective on that from experience and
that's not what this podcast is we just
talk to each other so
there may be some things that you want
us to talk about and you want to get our
opinion on but we just don't want to be
those
you know two dudes with a podcast
who are just giving their opinion about
things that they have no business giving
their opinion about we do that enough
already so this is not about our opinion
about things this is about our
experience and even with what link said
i'm sure that there may be some people
who are a little bit
offended by the fact that you said that
you're you're trying to there's some
good and there's some bad in your
experience of being in the middle of
this purity culture whereas there would
be some people would be like it's all
bad it's all unhealthy it's all toxic
and this was my experience and that is
your experience and we validate that
experience we acknowledge that
experience right but i think that it's
it's complex as we will explore
uh how we got from point a to point b
and some of the decisions that we made
along the way that were based on the
mindset that we had at the time
we may not agree with that mindset
anymore but we met we may be
happy with the where we're at now with
the result and that's not an endorsement
of that way of thinking it's just an
illustration of the fact that this is a
complex
subject and we're not giving our sort of
like final opinions on it we're just
telling you the story so hopefully that
helps to understand why there's certain
things that we may not address
all together but we are opening up to
questions in episode after next if we
continue at the pace that we're planning
that
now that we've adjusted and added an
episode so hashtag your biscuits let us
know
anything that you want us to talk about
related to sex that we might have only
glanced at or didn't talk about at all
and we'll choose the ones that we feel
like we have at least a little something
to say about hashtag or biscuits let us
know but let's get into this let's keep
going
i know that i was kind of mapping out
my
high school relationship and
how the physical
aspect of of of that relationship
started
and ultimately
defined so much of our relationship and
so much of my spiritual experience and
how i related to god to the point that
we broke up and it was it was it was
very heartbreaking scenario to break up
just because i ch basically i chose my
relationship with god over my
relationship with my girlfriend
at the time leading
like at so we broke up this
after my
freshman year yeah
of college
uh over that summer
and
um
that experience as you'll see had a
dramatic impact on
the decisions i made in terms of who i
was going to date next which ended up
being christy so i'll get into all that
but there is this whole year of being in
college and entering into
another level of purity culture so we
can kind of talk about that first yeah
i'll get back to like my dating
trajectory and yours and then i'll talk
about meeting jesse at this moment and
kind of at the peak of my purity but
we've covered a little bit about you
know you guys know if you've listened to
the podcast before a deconstruction
series and then a follow-up series like
we were involved in campus crusade for
christ
very involved and so what our freshman
year at nc state looked like is we went
from these guys who were in this
christian band who were being very
serious about their faith and also there
was a lot of accountability between the
two of us
meaning that we actually were involved
in each other's spiritual lives to kind
of hold each other to the standards that
we believe that we need to be held to
and so there was this like camaraderie
and it was it was our it was the two of
us it was our other bandmates then when
we get to college
the band's still happening but then we
dive head first into campus crusade for
christ
and
by the beginning of sophomore year
we had like
i'll speak for myself i was leading a
bible study
i was
um
the i was leading the weekly meeting i
was the emcee of the weekly meeting
i was like this public
christian right the crusade at the time
and probably still now is one of the if
not the largest student organization on
campus at state it wasn't that big at
first when when we started but there was
a few hundred students
that would come every single week and it
was like i was sort of setting myself up
as like yeah and it became i'm a
christian student
same for me but very much involved in
bible bible study involved in all the
retreats that they would offer like our
friend group was built within that
context
i had study partners from like my
engineering courses but we i weren't i
wasn't really friends with anybody
outside of
campus crusade like we were just so all
in
it's kind of like going to class and
study partners all that type of stuff
was like a
like a different world it's kind of like
work george versus home george from
seinfeld uh and i was
on stage like you were emceeing the
meetings i was on stage singing worship
songs and yeah and eventually helping
lead the worship band
so we were both very
visible representations of what a
campus crusader
looked and acted like and we held
ourselves to that stand and if you saw
us on campus you most likely knew us
through that like if you if you had come
to crusader or you're like you knew
somebody like
ourselves
in a position where
we
we knew that there was
like
a higher level of
accountability like people expected more
from us kind of it kind of felt like if
you go to church you you really hold
your pastors
or your priest or whatever the the
spiritual authority
in your life if if if if if you hadn't
want to have one you kind of hold them
to this higher standard
and we
we welcomed that because
it was just another way to
really
um
channel our motivations to serve god so
we didn't do it for the reputation or to
hold up the reputation but
it helped to reinforce what we what we
wanted to devote our lives to and that
was serving god and and
being devoted in in every way we could
being being as real as possible and not
dividing our lives and saying okay when
it comes to when it comes to sex or
purity and the word was thrown around a
lot
we wanted to be as serious as possible
and we were i mean this is god we're
talking about and i will say
uh
integrity has always been a thing that
is very important to us right it was
when we were in college it was after
college it is now like the whole idea of
saying one thing publicly and being
another thing in private has always been
something that i have a huge problem
with i know you do as well so it wasn't
just like oh these people see me i've
got to act this way in public it was
very serious and went all the way down
to the core of our existence and so it
wasn't something that was just an
outward external thing it was incredibly
personal
uh in an internal thing i wanted to kind
of explore just for context
some of the we talked a little bit in
the last episode about some of the
standards that we began to believe and
some of the things that we were told in
high school but when we got into crusade
there was a whole nother level of things
that got added on to this and there's
just a couple that i remember okay
guidelines and sort of ideas and rules
um
these are in no particular order i
remember being told don't study the
bible with a girl
because and definitely don't pray with a
girl because studying the bible
and praying are intimate things and if
you do this like alone if like you just
sit down with a girl and start reading
the bible which believe it or not is
probably something that could very well
have happened
uh it'll be
this killer day incredibly personal
thing that then oh you should end up
screwing each other yeah
you know because you've like
connected in this deep spiritual way
um i always thought that was an odd
thing but i was like okay and i i was
also very
apt to be like once i kind of
assimilated into a group
whatever these preachers and these
guests because the way that it would
work is we had guest speakers come in
every single week local pastors local
staff with other organizations sort of
like christian almost always dudes
almost always white dudes coming in to
kind of give their perspective and kind
of preach at you every single week and i
was just like a sponge man taking it all
in and they were like that was the
predisposition it was like whatever they
say i'm going to do because i want to
get this right yeah that was definitely
my mindset was i want to get this right
this this matters more than anything
and i want to demonstrate my devotion to
jesus
so
just tell me what to do and i will do it
tell me what not to do and i won't do it
i just want the system i want to know
that i'm okay right
so all you have to do is don't
masturbate that was a it was it was a
big thing like of course don't don't
look at porn
don't masturbate
and
i mean there was a bit of
yeah but it was a conscious struggle and
absolutely constant struggle and as when
it came to dealing with
women and also the advice for the women
uh
one thing was
side hugs if you come from a christian
culture you know about the side hug like
you're not supposed to hug
a woman because you don't want her
breasts
to come in contact with your chest which
would be erotic and scandalous and so
you there's literally this culture i
don't know if it's still happening but
there's a culture of side hugging which
just became the the normal greeting
for
all the ladies
oh i can side hug like the bread like
the best of them but it totally makes
sense when you're there there is
like you're trying to remove off
all physical aspects of any type of
relationship and remain
pure and i mean lust is something that
happens in your heart it's not something
that happens with your hands or
uh with parts of your body first so it
goes that deeply so you're trying to nip
any nip any sort of listen i told you
we're still we're 12 year old in the bud
12 year old boys i'm sorry we never
talked about sex this is explicitly on
the internet it says nip i'm going to go
for it you're nipping all this in the
bud of your thought life and saying
i mean
talk about thought life for a second
just as an aside and we'll get back to
the the side hug but
there's this principle of
taking every thought captive
so the principle was
you can you can sin in your heart and in
your mind by fixating or
by lusting after someone who's not your
partner
like your marriage partner and again
anything you would do like like lust
after somebody have a little fantasy
uh look at a girl's butt and say and
appreciate it
in a appreciate in a detailed way these
are
this is all
sinful
if you if you give into it
but it kind of left you with this
feeling of
even when the thought pops into my head
thoughts that
as a matter of fact are completely
normal
and
just
i would say instinctive
like
just to notice
someone and be attracted to to them
physically
there's nothing that that's just a
natural occurrence
that maybe the teaching wasn't that's
wrong but the takeaway behind the
teaching was
i i start to feel dirty by having
by experiencing what are actually
natural
impulses and instinctual occurrences and
it was being contextualized those
natural again this is inside baseball
christian stuff but
natural
natural man is sinful man natural man is
carnal man is according to the flesh
right there is a there's a distinction
between the flesh and the spirit and so
the flesh because of original sin
because of the original sin of of adam
were born with these carnal things so
what
yeah i'm not saying that there aren't
christians you would be like yes and you
need to totally find natural to be and
tamp it down but it's confusing for
somebody who's raging with hormones and
constantly like developing and again
this is my experience i mean some people
don't have
you know
some people are attracted to
the same sex some people attracted to
both sexes some people aren't attracted
to other sexes or anybody right but for
me i was like the default that i would
return to no matter how spiritual i was
being i was in the middle of leading a
weekly meeting i was in the middle of
leading a prayer i was in the middle of
teaching a bible study
i already explained how i felt felt
about vaginas
right and yes you did yeah and it
those
it would constantly return to my mind i
mean i was a horny dude right and so
it's just like in the midst of these
sort of sacred holy things you're going
back to this place you're like ah this
impure thought ah this impure thought
and again like you said a totally
natural thing but you begin to almost
hate yourself because you're dealing
with it on such
a regular basis it's like the default
mindset that you keep going back to and
you're being told that this is
something that you should be taking
every thought captive you should be
resisting this in a way that you really
can't it's like trying to hold back a
river it's tamping things down and
there's this pressure that builds so
that then you have to start
building these systems of protection so
that there's no one in your blast radius
you know what i'm saying so i know what
you're saying so side hugs actually make
sense when you're com when you're if the
standard is to not have sex when you're
not coming to grips with
i'm using all of these you said coming
and grips i just i'm just i'll try to
stop with with your own desires and
learning how to
acknowledge them and engage with them in
a healthy way that
always involves consent of course when
you involve somebody else but there's an
understanding of this is
this is a natural part of who i am and i
need to deal with it
in a
in a way that there's a there's a
healthy way to deal with it that doesn't
revolve around a center of shame but
that is that was not my experience my
experience was
this is wrong this is not
this has to be acknowledged to god every
single time it happens if i want to
continue to have a relationship with god
an active relationship with god
i need to keep confessing
and but what i'm saying is it it
it brings you to a point where you have
to say i can't hug a girl straight on
because
i'm
i am so pent up inside that
i fixate on the fact that i'm having
some some booby contact
right and it actually is just not you
know it's so you put these boundaries in
place where that's not gonna happen
versus
okay
there's a healthy way to deal with
what's going on in your body and in your
mind
and how you interact with other people
than just okay let's
let's not then let's just go a totally
different direction
that has nothing to do with it you can
only side hug not like there is a
healthy way to just hug somebody but
let's not have that conversation
let's have this let's be as pure as
possible what what uh what else
there's a couple more things on the list
and also i think it leads into a
conversation about what it said what it
was kind of the narrative that was being
painted about us by this whole thing
yeah we'll get into that one second i do
want to take this is ironic i want to
take the opportunity to draw your
attention to the uh ouija board oh god
this is hilarious
on my shirt yeah if if old if college us
would have would have seen current us
promoting well it's not a ouija board
it's the thing a ouija board controller
on a t-shirt it's the thing that you put
on the ouija board
for to collectively receive the messages
from the demons or say it himself if
you're lucky
um
and uh we're selling that shirt yeah we
are feeding our families
by selling a shirt
with something that we would have been
appalled at when we were in college in
the time that we're talking about today
isn't it life beautiful
now i think it's just
cool and harmless yeah right yeah but
maybe i'll change my
that during any mind yeah i think it's
just the collective mindset of the
people together and they're kind of just
moving it around i mean scientifically i
think that's what's happening you know
what go to mythical.com buy this shirt
rep your boys and get ready for the
shirt burning ceremony let's just put it
down okay awesome yeah
what else
what about the purse straps yeah so
there were these standards again as we
established last time most of these
standards ended up affecting the women
more than the men right
one was women were not supposed they
were supposed to be very conscious of
where their purse strap went and it
could not go between the boobies okay
because if it goes between the boobies
it really emphasizes those boobies and
those men are just gonna go [ __ ] a crazy
babies
and then also they had to be very
conscious of where their seat belt if
you get into a car with a man and you're
putting on your seatbelt
don't put the strap in between your
boobies because one of those tips is
going to pop up and be very visible
i don't know where you were supposed to
put it because
if you put it below it both of the
boobies come up if you put it above it i
think you'll choke in an accident this
is horrible advice
we needed a five-point harness what we
needed is a christian five-point harness
for women that can there was like a
built-in brazier that just covered the
boobs kept everything in place nothing's
jiggling nobody's stumbling a babysitter
we could have sold that i wish i could
go back in time and sell and upgrade
five-point harness for women riding in
cars with christians talking about
christian women in baby seats but really
what you're that no i'm just telling you
is that the heart it was
it was the myth it was the the teaching
was that men are animals the men are the
animal babies like they're the ones who
need to be
you know
you you've got to make these decisions
to protect them from themselves
to
keep them from stumbling
is the phrase yeah that is in the bible
i guess probably you you don't want you
don't want to cause your christian
brother to stumble so
don't put the strap in between your
booba loobs so again
so it became the women's responsibility
to protect the men from themselves but
one thing i will say is if you start
with a world view where people are
basically bad people are basically evil
people are basically carnal and sin i
mean in sex outside of a
heterosexual monogamous marriage is
always wrong that is the only context
you see how the
these standards get put on top of that
to keep you from the sin right i'm not
saying it's right i'm just saying it's
logical if that's where you start i
don't start there anymore so it all
seems crazy to me and if you don't have
that standard as well it all seems crazy
and the reality is is that because
people are
naturally sexually active and people
going screw right it happens
and because that's the way people's
bodies work that doesn't mean just let
it all hang out and there's no standards
at all but i'm saying that when you tamp
down to this degree
you end up damaging people in ways that
you end up finding out later in life
exactly what that damage was you begin
to
you begin to wake up and
realize oh that was very damaging what
we were doing especially to those women
especially to anyone who was struggling
with anything except a very specific
heterosexual attraction yeah the damage
that was being done to all those people
was just
it wasn't even on the radar we weren't
thinking about what we were doing we
thought we're keeping people from having
sex outside of marriage and so this must
be good
but it was creating this
for us it was just like you know we
heard about pastors who would have
standards like i don't get on an
elevator
with a woman
i do not ever let a woman into my office
i would never have a woman in my office
and close the door without somebody else
and then you're like
and at the time you're like this is good
yes this guy understands
that the standard he understands the
standard and he's making the good smart
moves but there's a whole bunch of stuff
that's wrapped up in that one of the
things you're doing is you're saying
that you can't trust yourself that being
alone with a woman in an elevator the
only option or like like
can you maybe we can just learn to
control ourselves and also what about
the woman
she's there too she has the ability to
say yes or no she actually has a will of
her own and you're treating her like
the whole every scenario is just set up
like the woman is this object
of desire
and that all all that she can do is
either increase your sexual attraction
to her or increase the risk that you're
going to have around her
and you are an animal and you've got to
keep yourself in a cage
whereas what if what would it be like to
be like maybe i'll try to ride on an
elevator with a woman and see what
happens you know maybe i can get to the
seventh floor without you know making
out with her come on think about what
you're saying about yourself we had this
belief
that you couldn't be friends with
we couldn't be friends with a girl
really i mean we had we grew up with
friends who were girls but then like we
kind of distanced ourselves over time
and we especially if you dated somebody
and then afterward and this is
complicated maybe off topic but like you
what we definitely had this belief that
like you can never be friends with them
afterwards like because there's too much
it's everything is sexually charged
right um and again i feel like it's just
not coming to grips with the reality of
what was happening
from a biological
standpoint
that
it yeah it it got to this point very
quickly and like a sponge i soaked it up
because i wanted that system
when it came to
masturbation we didn't want
we as guys we would talk about it but
you know i don't know that the girls
were talking about it i ne i did not
believe that any girl masturbated or
looked at porn or looked at porn we
believe that they just did not do that
and because it was the guys who had to
be controlled and protected from
themselves and so that that was kind of
the message i got was that
and girls aren't into sex and that was
the message that the women were getting
as well by the way they were they so the
ones that were masturbating which is
probably all of them
you know what were they feeling like at
the time it's like i don't ever feel
like anybody i mean the boys are talking
about masturbation all the time they go
to these conferences and they talk about
porn and masturbation well i'm
interested in those things too
but i guess i'm weird because we're not
talking about it we're just talking
about purity rings right yeah the guys
didn't get a purity ring and the guys
didn't go to a dance with their mom and
and
promised to their mom at a dance that
they weren't going to have sex
until they got married purity balls talk
about balls and if you search purity
culture just amongst podcasts i've
listened to a number of podcasts
and they're most all
women sharing their perspectives so it's
out there i encourage you to
search that if you're interested in that
perspective
and
there is a talk about like guys kind of
like getting together and joking about
masturbating there was kind of this wink
wink you know it's like
we know looking at porn is something you
shouldn't do but it happens and but i
would say for me
i was so dedicated that i i never let
myself off the hook
and we as a as a friend group within
crew like we were very serious about
given the circumstances
that we've already described about
holding each other accountable and being
as as holy as possible we made a chart
in our apartment and everybody's name
was on the left side and then there were
star star star stickers no you you must
have made this chart and you because i
vaguely remember it and every time you
masturbated you were supposed to put a
star on the chart which is a little i
mean there should have been like a
thumbs down to confess to everybody
that you did it we also had a rule that
the bathroom doors would not be shut i
do remember that so if you were dropping
a deuce the door had to be cracked if
you were taking a shower the door had to
be cracked and anyone you invited any
other roommate to just at any moment
just kick that crack door open and make
sure you weren't
bopping the bishop
yanking the yankee you've got some
interesting euphemisms i think it's
shaking hands with a pope shaking hands
with it but you can bop the bishop but i
didn't because
the bathroom door was open well i found
a way
i could always find a way were you
actually like abiding by the rule i'm
sure you you're abiding by the rules of
the show
i mean i'd put a star out there but i
didn't want to put as many stars as i
needed to so you were lying well we
didn't have enough stars and and here i
was being totally
forthright
and because that's the only way i could
feel good
is if i was
if i remain pure and the thing about
purity as a word is
it's
it's like a light switch
you either are you aren't you're either
pure or you're not it's it's an all in
game that's that's the problem with that
word is that there's no room for there's
no room for error or new nuance it's not
a spectrum you've either failed or
you've succeeded well it's like you've
got a bucket or you're tainted it's like
there's no image there's two buckets
there's the the purity bucket and then
there's the syn bucket and all sin is
sent before god and disqualifying in the
same way so
if you have that sort of theological
perspective what ends up happening a lot
of time is once you do start sinning
whether that's masturbation looking at
porn messing around with your girlfriend
once you're in the sim bucket there's no
it's all it's there's no longer a matter
of degree it's like why am i going to
stop doing this at this point because
i'm in the sim bucket this is all sin i
think that happens a lot of times
because it's not a question of is this
healthy or like is there what is the net
benefit of this behavior it's just is it
wrong or is it right and if it's wrong
you know
masturbation
from a
spiritual standpoint is no more wrong or
no less wrong than just having full
sexual intercourse with your girlfriend
now i know
from a technical teaching standpoint we
didn't really no one really thought that
because it's crazy to think that but
technically according to
a theological viewpoint of sin there is
no difference and so i exp i experienced
like becoming impure every time that i
would i would
i would take an action like that well
and the funny thing is is that we're
sitting here talking about girls not
putting purse straps in between their
boobs and not putting the seat belt on
and wearing the right clothes not
showing cleavage not wearing tight pants
oh don't wear the tight pants in the
meantime i'm going to to my computer and
looking at just straight up boobs
without a seat belt there's no seat belt
no shirt no purse strap it's just boobs
just in the air it's called porn
you should look into it and
the funny thing is is that
it's just it kind of demonstrates why
did you do this
uh we had a computer at home but it
wasn't hours i would
i would find a
corner facing away from
the computer lab of course in the
computer lab
like in it i wouldn't do it in a way
that anybody could see it because that's
a weird situation i would be alone and i
brought you jerk off in the corner i
didn't computer jerk off in the computer
lab i looked at porn what kind of person
do you think i am i would look at the
porn and i would take that thought with
me to a bathroom and then that's where i
would do the deed i'm not going to
freaking do that like a public i'm not a
creep a public restroom though because
the ones at home we had to keep the door
open uh okay so did you are you telling
me you didn't masturbate in college
like i i don't think you should be
questioning me i think i should be
questioning you are you telling me you
didn't masturbate in college i certainly
did yes so what do you go into a tent
somewhere in the woods i but i it it
doesn't take me terrifies me i would
have loved to have had the
uh gumption to look at
porn in the computer lab but it
terrified me to the point where i would
never do that well well i don't and you
know what i may have done it and blocked
it out of my mind but where else i
didn't have a computer where else would
i get porn and again i it was i was
trying really i'm talking i'm talking
you had a realistic approach and you
late at night there's maybe one other
person in there they're on the other
side of the thing i'm facing away i mean
there's a wall in a wall behind me i
never got caught no one ever saw me do
it
so it wasn't like i was in this
situation where like i because again i
want to be very clear people who like go
to the library and like look at porn at
the library where people can see them
doing it that's like
basically
sexual harassment right so i did i did
not do this anyway this was a completely
private affair but i just there was the
only computer that i had and also i'm
not i'm not judging you for it well it
sounded like it i i just i'm just i was
just giving you a hard time because i
thought it was funny what i
the reason why i didn't do it was
because of the judgment the wrath of god
you know not the wrath of god but just
the the temporary rejection until i got
up the gumption to
confess
and clear the air with god because i
felt like i treated god very
transactionally all right once i do
anything wrong i have to confess it in
order to clear the air and re-establish
our
active relationship and conversation i i
believe that i couldn't have a
conversation with god until i confessed
something that was standing in the way
and that was so much the focus that was
the main thing
and i just didn't want to do that i'd
like to get into
this
this dovetails into the dating but is
there anything else you want to hit
before we get into my approach to that
well no because i think it i mean the
the last thing i'll say is that
we were continuing to because the thing
i don't wanna i i like we're different
people for the record i don't think it's
creepy that you were looking at porn in
the computer lab i think well i'm sure
some people i think it's funny but it
was the only option hey i understand why
the only thing that kept me from it was
guilt it wasn't anything else but i want
to be clear about it and i want to be
clear about the fact that i'm not saying
i wasn't guilty i'm not saying i wasn't
incredibly ashamed of doing it
i'm just saying that my
drive to look at it was something i
could not control i honestly
got to i could i like i could not it was
there it was new it was evolving porn
was evolving in crazy ways in the late
90s internet connections were evolving
in crazy ways and it was moving from
pictures to video like
the world like today it's like
all access all the time
whatever you want
back then it was
i was on like the i was like on the
frontier in one sense you know of like
finding this new stuff
and it was irresistible overwhelming
all-consuming
and
in spite of that strong
sort of compulsion because i still was
very
serious about all this christian stuff i
would say that over the course of a year
in college you could count on one hand
my right hand
uh the number of times that i would
look at porn in the computer lab so what
i'm getting at is it was mostly it was a
thought thing i didn't need porn i count
on my left hand by the way which is
weird i needed
more evidence that you're left-handed
but the uh i i all i needed was the
thoughts and the place to do it you know
so it was more of a thought life and a
masturbation thing than it was a porn
thing but i'm just giving you an example
of it was so awe-consuming that i would
take that it was still a risk i mean
first of all i'm like logged into my
like school account i don't know if
they're tracking me i don't know how
this works i didn't really care right
i knew a bunch of other dudes were doing
it too so
um but just to to contextualize that
so
i was kind of at the height of my purity
and there were some is still doing these
things the only times i ever went
without masturbating was two summer
projects
like i went on two extended like six
week summer projects for a crusade where
it's like you're just in this incredible
spiritual environment and i went the
whole time without jerking off and just
felt like a king and it lasted about a
week after that
uh those are my two longest stints i
mean
you can look at the chart and tell
what my longest stint was i don't
remember what it was but my chart was
truthful you were the only one trust me
yeah such a
such a one such a rule follower
but
my experience
experience in high school and freshman
year of
of dating and everything i talked about
in the previous episode
it again it was so it was so
heartbreaking to break up on those terms
and
sent me into what i realized was a
depression for most of well most of the
first half of my sophomore year of
uh college because we broke up over the
summer and then i was just kind of the
aftermath of that but i was determined
and i was talking to my discipler and
bible study leader and uh more than we
were talking but i mean again we were
put into place these systems and we were
listening to all these speakers but i
was i was talking to him as a mentor and
just trying to figure out i don't want
to make
the the mistakes that i made i want to
embrace everything from us from a rules
and systems standpoint to protect my
heart from having that type of
heartbreak again
and i i did not want to be dating
somebody or fall in love with somebody
and then
have to make a decision between them and
god
because i knew
obviously the right answer is you have
to choose god
you know there was it was never a
question in my mind so i did i just
didn't want to have to break up with my
next
girlfriend which i anticipated would be
really serious because of the way i was
looking at it
um
and so that was my mindset also
i mean
in approaching dating and and and
thinking about it in terms of like
finding a marriage partner
my whole all of my dad's stuff came up
too like my my dad leaving my mom before
i was around two years old and then
just vowing to never make
that mistake right um
so i wa you know i i wanted to do
everything right i desperately wanted to
please god
and be
okay
and i never read i kiss dating goodbye
that book came out around this time
maybe a few years earlier joshua harris
now as he's
he's not a christian anymore any and
he's taking the book out of print
because of how it's it reinforced purity
culture
but i know that a lot of the principles
from it i ended up applying even though
i didn't
same same deal i didn't read it but we
knew all the principles was like okay i
get it i get it you know there were
terms thrown around like you want to
you want to guard your heart which i
guess is what i'm describing from
heartbreak and you want to protect
whoever you're dating you want to guard
their heart too because you want to
treat whoever you're dating
in a way that preserves them
for whoever they're they're going to
marry if it's not you
and you want to preserve yourself if
it's not them
so
the fall of sophomore year towards is
when christie and i met and
i wanted to start dating her and i so
right from the beginning i was like all
right
i want to be very methodical and uh and
slow paced about this i wanted to be
very calculated our first date was by
design a group date
that was that was something that was a
thing
so your first date was a group date
it was great when your bible study your
mens again these were not co-ed bible
studies intervarsity scandalous they
would do that campus crusade would never
do that so the men's bible study would
pick a women's bible study and come up
with like an elaborate way to ask them
out on a group date that's cute my bible
study did that with some girls over at
peace dates do take off the pressure of
a date in a way it's like do i really
like you do i really want to have a
one-on-one date of course with christy i
certainly did
we went out on
our second date which was just the two
of us
and then was there an elevator involved
there was you would have never done that
yeah i don't think there was an elevator
but i was
you know
she started getting involved in campus
crusade she came from a background of um
she went she went to church her whole
life but it wasn't this like
all-encompassing devout crusade level
thing that when she got involved in
crusade she didn't know she didn't know
half of what she was getting into right
about how devout we were and how devout
i was
but
so when i would say
you know what i want to
i only want us to talk on the phone
once a week
we can kind of pick like a phone date
and then maybe once a month we can go
out on a date like early on in our
relationship i was saying things like
that because i i knew that like if this
really started to pick up steam i was
going to have to start making these
decisions
about a physical relationship and it was
just really scary
to
to start to flirt with going back to
to that battle
that i had with my previous girlfriend i
didn't want to do that
um and christy's like
the way she
characterizes it now her perspective is
like that was it was strange it was
strange even within the like i never
questioned it at the time i thought
link's a little odd but i know you so
much better now than i did then which is
the weird thing and so because i know
myself that much better as well and it
was like i i didn't know why i i
supported
you deep down i supported it because it
felt like your particular application of
the system that we were all sort of
subscribing to
but it never like
it never really registered with me just
how
strict of a system it was like seeing
each other once a month yeah that's what
you're gonna see each other
for the first few months and then i
think we started picking up steam you
saw her at the weekly meeting every week
but but a date was started out once a
month and then only talking on the phone
once a week and we didn't we didn't
email each other and there was no text
that didn't happen exactly they didn't
have cell phones um
and
as we started getting more serious and i
guess it got to the point where you
might start to feel like
a normal couple would say that they love
each other is when i said i'm not i just
want you to know that my
my perspective on love and this was kind
of something i invented this was not
like a bible teaching
but it was again i just wanted i wanted
to take the most devout stance i could i
told her i was like listen
i'm not gonna tell anyone
i'm dating that i love them
until
i know i want to be within the rest of
my life
so
if you hear me say i love you it
basically means will you marry me right
and she was like this is this is strange
she didn't say that that's in the book
by the way yeah but what she said was he
didn't really come up with it what book
i guess dating about oh it is see i
never read the book but i took all the
principles from it through advice i was
getting
i'm surprised i didn't read the book but
um
christie was like there was also
something appealing about someone who
was so devoted to god and devoted to her
purity as well as my own that's what
they were being the all the women that's
what they were being told
this is the kind of guy you want yeah
that's what the women were being told in
their breakout sessions and their
conferences is that you want a man who
is running towards the lord with passion
so basically
because he's going to be he's going to
be the spiritual leader he's going to be
in charge of your spiritual life your
children's spiritual life the rest of
your life you got to make this choice
you got to get this right run towards
god as hard as you can and then look to
your left or right and see who's running
with you and that's who you should be
with yeah was another analogy but then
kind of follow him a little bit and yeah
and i so i wanted to do that we we
didn't hold hands or
really touch in all of our all of our
dating life we
we knew we weren't going to kiss
well i think we talked about
we might wait until we get married to
kiss
she uh we started dating that sophomore
year by the next summer
i went on a summer project for 10
maybe it was 11 weeks in santa cruz
she was staying back home
and i basically broke up with her
because i said you know i want to devote
i don't want to have this long-distance
relationship thing going on i want i
want you to be able to devote yourself
fully to god and not have to worry about
me and i want to be able to do that in
santa cruz too now i didn't date any
other girls and we still talk you dated
god i dated god but we too and we still
talked we wrote letters
um to each other and i think we did hop
on the phone some my granddad passed
away in the middle of that and i came
home she
she met me you were gone you were also
on my project
like all of my close guy friends not
masturbating at all were also
uh
gone
and it was that was a very pivotal
moment in our dating relationship even
though we weren't technically dating
when she was there for me
for the funeral and the
you know dealing with the grief of
losing my grandad and it really bonded
us together
and we were both seeing each other a
devotion to god that was extremely
attractive and it was there was so much
alignment
i came back from
uh that summer and
we dated more seriously so much so that
by the next summer when she went on
summer project without me to santa cruz
same place even though there's lots of
places she could have gone
um
we didn't break up
in fact that was the summer when i was
trying to figure out
i want to do the right thing is she the
right one god give me a sign
and if not i'm just going to read all
these books so i can write a
dissertation on why we should be
together
the moment she got home from santa cruz
that night is when even though i didn't
have a ring i got down on one knee in
her parents
yard
and proposed
and
right after i proposed and she said yes
and i explained why i didn't have a ring
but i promised i was going to get one
that's why you didn't ever i was
supposed to propose two weeks from now
that was the agreement i had with your
parents because they were going to keep
this secret but i couldn't keep the
secret again so much
pent up a lot of pressure pressure
that she said yes i stood up and that
was the first time we kissed how was it
it was after we got engaged immediately
tongue definitely tongue wow you went on
not kissing not holding hands to tongues
it's like riding a bike
i mean
i and it all came back to me but even
better this time
but i wasn't like pedaling
i wasn't straddling her
but that did happen later which we'll
talk about when we talk about our
engagement so yeah i mean throughout our
whole dating i remember the first time
we held hands it was just like an
emotional
it i mean i almost [ __ ] in my pants
yeah it didn't take much back then
because yeah when you
were dating for months and months and
then like
the we when we held hands on the beach
that day it was like it was like sparks
and it was like a in i mean it was like
a
flames it was it was amazingly hot and
there's that's kind of cool well here's
the thing there's an aspect of this that
like i could imagine
i had i don't read romance novels
my wife does uh i could imagine a
romance novel that was basically based
on this like these two people committed
to this ideology and they're super pure
and then the moment they finally just
let themselves hold hands like yeah
there's something beautiful
about
waiting
and then experiencing that it makes that
moment this electric moment now that
does not mean that i'm not dismissing
all the other [ __ ] that comes as a
result of that way of thinking but you
can't argue with the fact that if you
take two different perspectives one
perspective is sex is just a biological
thing it doesn't mean anything as long
as you have it protected you should have
it with whoever you want whenever you
want however you want that's one end of
the spectrum and the other end of the
spectrum is this is the super sacred
spiritual
thing that has to be protected it should
only happen with one person in the
certain context for the rest of your
life
well
in one of those scenarios the potential
for the sexual experience or any sort of
sexual contact or physical contact being
electric and special and sort of like
over-the-top overwhelming it's going to
be the end of the spectrum where they
put it on this pedestal just that's just
the way it's the delay delay
gratification
sort of uh psychological thing right so
you basically
lived that
um i lived my own version of that which
i'll explain when you're done with this
i think i i'm gonna stop right here at
engagement and let you bring you i want
to bring you up to engagement too and
then we can talk about what engagement
was like because that was a whole year
for me yep uh before we got married um
so with you and jesse so when you were
on summer project in 1998
uh
trying to date god and not date christy
i was trying to date god and not jerk
off and successfully did so
um
i had never met jesse but i got back
from
uh that summer project and i had broken
up with my pretty serious girlfriend
uh that i dated my fresh like freshman
sophomore-ish year of
pretty long relationship like freshman
and half a sophomore and she was a
christian as well she wasn't in purity
culture into this degree that i was but
i was again i wasn't good at it not
masturbating and not looking at porn but
i was really good at not doing stuff
like drawing the line
again at the waist with my girlfriend
and so i was
basically
pretty pure in that regard right i had
figured out some way to like
manage myself in relationships yeah
which often involves
masturbating after dates
um but i was not i am not uh i'm
compared to you i'm not a systematic
person compared to the general
population yes compared to you no
um
but i was committed and i to this
to the whole deal i was all in i knew i
was going to do my best and not have sex
before i got married i was buying into
the principles of i guess dating about i
don't think i read the book i think i
might have gone to like a talk where
they like i don't know i but i i bought
into the principles to a degree
understanding that the whole idea of
like once the physical relationship
starts it's going to quickly move
towards
you know sex and like that only happens
in marriage should like just don't do
that in fact don't even date i i was
like i kind of agree with that but i'm
very much a broad strokes kind of guy so
i'm like i get what you're going for i
think i can achieve it in my own way
strokes
so i meet jessie
and
i just think that she's wonderful and
beautiful uh and of course it was a
slightly different time
she was
a senior in high school at the time at
the time okay
so i basically was like
well i'm not going to date her because
because he's in high school she's full
stop i'm not going to date somebody
who's in high school while i'm while i'm
in college so but she's going to be in
college eventually and so i should at
least maintain some level of friendship
or contact
um
but basically the way i would sum up
that that year of her like her senior
year in high school
was
maintaining a friendship from from a
distance and then like they're in again
our families were connected so it was
kind of it was not a dating relationship
meaning they went to this thing they
went to the same church
and and kind of knew each other and so
there were like church events that i
would kind of go home and i could talk
to her and we would kind of like we
would hang out a little bit
these were essentially dates without
calling them dates and there was
zero physical contact n i didn't even i
didn't open the door for her i didn't do
anything gentlemanly because i did not
want to communicate that this was a
dating relationship not just because of
my commitment to purity but because it
was like she's in high school i don't
think i'm not gonna date somebody in
high school i'll be friends with this
person yeah but like i said i knew that
she was going to be in college the
following year and so i go on my second
summer project to slovakia
i didn't i didn't masturbate in europe i
mean give me some kind of credit here i
mean i went to europe good job
good job uh i uh
i get back from
from that time and i'm thinking to
myself like okay she's gonna be in
college
i'm in college
i think that she's amazing
and great
and beautiful
and i
want to basically begin a relationship
with her
um and
what i ended up doing again we have been
taught about like you know there are
lots of acronyms in crew one was dtr
which is defining the relationship oh
yeah and a lot of times again because of
there's a very patriarchal under or if
not overcurrent to the whole way the
evangelical christianity works
especially in the late 90s it was the
guy's job to say it was the guy's job to
do it this is what's happening here yeah
the guy had to define the relationship
and basically it was almost like
yeah you just assume
the girl's going to go along with this i
don't even know what the thought was but
what i did is i got back from that
knowing that i really liked her and what
i told her was
i really like you
um
i
oh actually you know what i'm sorry i'm
i'll get my timeline confused i told her
this before
before before i went on summer project
and this is this is how i managed the
whole she's in high school thing is i
was basically like
i like you i will let you know when i am
ready for a relationship or something
crazy like that i'm sure she loved that
and here and here's the thing about
jesse is that yes you came from a
christian family and a church background
and she was super committed super
committed christian
but she hadn't really bought into the
ikea's dating goodbye and the purity
culture thing yet oh mostly because she
hadn't gotten involved in like a group
like crew yet
and also she's a little bit she has a
rebellious streak if you start telling
her too many things she's going to be
like oh let's question this and she at
the time was like
offended by that as she should have been
and be like what it's your job to tell
me when you're ready for a relationship
well i'll tell you when i'm ready for a
relationship but we maintain this sort
of like friendly banter when i got back
from uh summer project and i said i'm
ready for my relationship
she was like well that's not how it
works
i'm not ready for the relationship now
the fact is is that we were crazy about
each other and she was ready for the
relationship but she was bristling at
the idea of the dude just comes back and
just declares that he is available for
the relationship and it automatically
starts we waited a couple of weeks and
then we were in a relationship
but the funny thing that happened was is
that and she's going to be better at
remembering the specific timeline and we
do and they will be on the next episode
i don't know if we'll discuss this but
jesse and chrissy are joining us for the
next episode
i remember distinctly what happened was
as i'm trying to be this professional
christian dude
uh
and i'm really really trying hard to be
pure in both appearance and in the way
i'm conducting this relationship
and so there was still no physical
contact
i think
there was a couple of hand-holding
things that had happened
but literally just like a hand-holding
you know i didn't have like the specific
standard that you did i'm going to wait
to hold hands
but i was like i'm gonna play this by
ear but i know i'm not anywhere near
kissing her at this point
and
i was over at her house after church
and there was a bunch of there's other
people at her house and like i could
tell that something was wrong with her
and like we kind of go into this room
together just the two of us in a room
can you believe that i was willing to do
that
we even shut the door
she seemed upset i said
what is wrong and she was kind of
articulating that like
you're not acting like
you're not acting like you're interested
in me like you're not sending any
signals that you're interested in me
like you obviously want to hang out with
me we have great conversation we make
each other laugh we're obviously into
each other intellectually and i believe
physically but there's no indication of
that you're not doing anything and and
so
she was sitting next to me
and
i was like what do you need
and i put my hand on her you grabbed her
forearm her forearm okay
um and she said
more of that
she liked the forearm touching huh
um and so
at that point yeah it was i mean yeah
the the
keeping physical out of it and not
explaining why
is extremely confusing but let me tell
you what happened when she said more of
that all the standards went out the
window and she ended up what i i kind of
just grabbed her and she crawled up and
sat in my lap where i'm sitting down on
the floor of this room she's sitting on
my lap and we just embraced i didn't
kiss her which is
freaking weird but i just kissed her and
we just held each other you just said
you kissed her i didn't kiss her okay i
did not kiss her i didn't kiss her which
is weird yes to like just embrace
somebody
and just like hold them and like feel
what it feels like to be physically
connected to another human that you're
physically attracted to which is totally
normal
um yeah but it was like electric it was
intoxicating it was over the top
and that was the beginning of us like
kind of officially being in a
relationship now and then you started
yeah i mean if you hadn't you started
explaining
why you're not kissing her well i
yeah i think she already knew but she
thought it was kind of weird to be like
why are you drawing the line at this
place and like it's like let's just you
know i don't or did you kiss so that was
in the fall and it wasn't until like we
basically had this relationship that was
just like lots of hand like and you can
make hand holding super intense oh yeah
there's there's ten fingers you know
yeah in this lots
of configurations like you could do this
you could do the interlocking you can
just do the open palm and just grab like
that you could do the little pinky
square technique christie and i have
this this is correct
index finger and that's that's how we
hold hands to this day it's like we
invented that but yeah so there's like a
savorine there's like a meditative
nature to
i i think there's a form of
sexual yoga where you deny yourself and
like there is i think we knew someone
involved
i think we were kind of in like
inventing the christian hand-holding
version of that uh quite possibly
that continued for several months
actually went all the way from the fall
to i remember there was
for valentine's day
now the previous year
there had been a valentine's day banquet
uh at her dad's like office like in
upstairs in his office in fukuoka
there's like the nice sort of like
banquet area yeah grace community had a
valentine's day banquet and i didn't
want to go to her with it because she
was in high school and it was weird but
like all of our families
wanted us to go like my family her
family my
everybody thought that we should go to
this thing together but i was afraid to
ask her because i thought it was weird
this is back in time by the way but i'm
going back to her senior year in high
school and then
what ends up happening is like the night
before i'm like hey you want to go to
the valentine's day bakewell because i
felt like kind of pressured and i wanted
to go but i didn't want to make it seem
like a big deal i'm trying to navigate
this weird world where i'm trying not to
be in a relationship and also really
want to be in one
she said she's i think she yeah she said
yes and we went but it was weird and she
was kind of mad at me so a year later
during valentine's day
i had this idea to basically redo the
valentine's day banquet just for us and
you know
my mom and her mom basically created
like this meal
and like made it look like it was a
banquet and we'd like both dressed up
and we just set up there and ate a meal
together and then we like we had music
and we started dancing and it was
and
during that dance you had you had
clothes on sex
no i was like
i'm i'm kissing her man i mean i'm not
this is stupid this is stupid that
joshua's stuff is stupid
so this was your first kiss and i kissed
her and uh
we kissed
for a long time you know how it is like
when you haven't kissed somebody and
you've been holding yourself back like
you kissed your like lips are raw you
know
and it was intense it was awesome and it
basically that was the beginning of us
just kissing a lot
kissing a lot i don't think you talked
to me about it that much because it just
made me mad that like somehow
you were okay with this but i couldn't i
could i had set my standard and now
and made my commitments to myself and
explain those to christy and like gotten
her on board with it
that then it was like i can't go back on
my own standards then i become a
a hypocrite but it was it was and so and
it was an expression of our per and i
was jealous are different personalities
interacting with the same ideology and
system yes i was going to navigate in a
way that kept me from the thing that i
was like what is the thing that we're
really trying to keep ourselves from i'm
going to wiener out of the vagina i'm
going to keep that oh and again i'm like
i'm not going below the waist i kind of
still had that standard
and also i didn't we didn't end up i
didn't even mess with the boobies i was
like that was a little i was more
righteous
there was just a lot of kissing that
happened and the but then the lust
that's happening in your head and heart
i guess
is something that's grounds for
confession do you recall
having a similar experience to me
in how you took all of this back to god
in like prayer life or journal life i
did i
in terms i completely separated the two
i thought that what was happening in my
thought life and the sort of like
continuing to masturbate that
was sinful and that was like me letting
god down
i felt zero guilt about making out with
jesse yeah because i was like i i was
like this is natural this is normal and
i'm and like we're actually controlling
ourselves really really well yeah and i
didn't think kissing was wrong i just
didn't want to get myself back into a
situation where then we had to break up
yeah yeah um but so once we got engaged
and we kissed i don't
i'll have to ask christy i don't know if
if we knew well i told her that i loved
her and then she knew i was that this
was the proposal because i followed
through on that yeah when i got down on
one knee i had this i had this speech i
said i love you and then i hit one knee
so before i hit the knee she knew what
was happening because i because i said i
loved her yeah i can't remember if she
expected us to make out
but i
i bet you we talked about that too
no i don't think we did because it was a
total it was a total surprise that i was
gonna
propose
to her and me and her parents
um
so
i'll have to ask her but most likely our
first kiss was
like yours spontaneous spontaneous
expression of exaltation
it was it it was amazing and again
there's a lot there
you can
and many christian couples know this
kissing can go a long way like like if
you have made this commitment to not do
anything else but kiss like you can
explore the depths
of kissing and it can be kind of a
beautiful thing and but it is
frustrating but i you know there was a
couple of factors and i think this
applies to both of us
is that uh we were not at the same
school i mean christy was close by but
like jesse was at carolina i was at
state christie wasn't meredith you were
still yeah we had to we had to have
dates in order to meet up i was busy i
was doing stuff all the time so were you
so was jessie so
i would go and see her on the weekends
we'd have like a date we like we would
date like we would hang out like friday
we'd hang out again saturday like we
would and then a lot of times we would
go back home and kind of hang out at uh
her parents house on sunday but but
you're saying that from a physical
relationship limited opportunity
tempered it it made it where it's like
oh i feel like we can get through this
and i was i mean once once february
rolled around and i was making out with
her i was like i'm i know that i'm going
to marry this girl
and she probably thinks that as well but
she's a freaking freshman in college i'm
a what was i junior at the time yeah but
fast forward for me i went on the the
um
second summer project well i get
confused oh no when i went on this
i'm very confused because i think when i
came back no it wasn't it was when did
you get engaged it was this start with
that i got engaged after her freshman
year so basically like we're making out
in february
and then in um
whenever it was i don't remember when
was no she went i stayed at home she
went to summer project between her
freshman and sophomore year she came out
to l.a and was on summer project when
she got back from summer project i'd got
in the ring i'd gotten i talked to her
dad
i asked her
to marry me right she said yes and we
were engaged for her sophomore year in
in college and then we got married
before her junior year
in college so we had a short engagement
and that in that entire well now so
that's i've caught up to the point of
view
your engagement was half as long as mine
once chrissy and i started you're
engaged for more than a year uh
yeah she got back well it was the end of
summer we got engaged and then
when we graduated that was our senior
year when we graduated we got engaged we
got married at the end of on may 27th so
that's one year yeah
and so we were engaged for one year as
well oh okay well
that's a that's a long time when now
you've
you've lit the fuse
which is starting to make out
that leads to the atomic bomb of sexual
intercourse that is an analogy that i
set in a talk to
younger college students about why i
decided not to kiss because it made it
so hard to just not
go all the way
way too much you're in a makeout session
i mean and then christy and i really
discovered that it was like we had so
much pent up uh
attraction
and physical
hopes for each other that you know once
we started making out over the course of
our engagement
i knew that we weren't going to have sex
like we just cannot have sex even though
it's just isn't it just a formality no i
cannot we cannot i cannot allow myself
to have those thoughts
like i want to prove to her that i'm the
man that she needs to marry like i got
to stay strong but
i mean once you start making out then
you know your bodies have a way of
aligning
and even if you're fully clothed
your bodies have a way of wanting to
make sex happen
even if you're not willing to take your
clothes off you know what i'm saying i'm
talking about a little gene grinding yep
you're talking about dry humping i'm
talking about dry humping and you've got
to be
you got to be strategic about what
clothes you wear on a date if you think
that's going to happen don't wear grace
weapons but that's premeditated you know
you want to wear something dark i should
i mean but i was thinking i need to wear
like a
a suit of armor yeah right like what am
i going gonna do here underwear made
made out of kevlar
and um
it was tough i mean we would so we we
would like okay we're gonna only we're
only gonna go out on dates in public
we're not going to come back to my
apartment and lay down on my bed and
make out anymore there's lots of laying
down and making out
that's trouble don't get horizontal
these are all things that like your
parents would like put rules if you were
dating somebody in like high school
maybe middle school but like so like it
i was just having a lot of that
experience and we were developing rules
ourselves like okay let's just have a
picnic out here in the middle of this
park
there's no way
we'll start
humping each other here in this park
will we well yes there is
in the broad freaking daylight it was it
was crazy man well i mean it was so
difficult
there was oh man we we should have
eloped well i remember one time it was
talking about being horizontal we were
at jessie's uh parents place down at the
beach and her granddad papa main rest in
peace was there and he uh kind of came
in
to the to the basement where we were and
we were lying down on the couch watching
a movie together with a blanket over us
and again
as i'll explain i was we stayed pretty
pure i'll tell you exactly how pure we
stayed in a second but at that time all
we're doing is just basically like
laying down together and making out and
there might be some incidental
boob contact but there's no like
unbuttoning the shirt and stuff it was
just like i was being freaking good man
because i was like listen i've got a
lifetime of sex just around the corner
when we get married in june and so i'm
just gonna respect her respect myself
and get through this yeah but papa comes
in he's like
uh what are you all doing
and jesse was like we're we're we're
we're um oh i set the story up wrong
it was the morning and we were down
there laying down together in the
morning okay and then he comes in and
you can see the look on his face and
jesse says papa we weren't down here all
night
and he was like it doesn't take all
night and just shuts the door and walks
out
yeah it could happen
it could happen in a second
especially when you're especially at
that age really geared up yeah geared up
to go but this is the interesting thing
about about you and christy because you
have been so good you have been so much
better than me like yeah but better
being more pure
jesse and i've been making out and then
during the engagement we made out i
think there was a dry humping session
that ended in the usual way it's much
better for the man let's just be honest
um and there was some incidental
maybe some maybe some purposeful
intentional boob contact at some point i
can't really remember but we basically
did not get into any uh let's say heavy
petting situations and there was really
no actual sexual contact
until our wedding night which we'll talk
about next time but
you guys
my impression from you was that you were
like the dry hump kings king and queen
like the the dry humping became
[Music]
became sort of the go-to for y'all it
was
it was never anything that we we just
embraced and said this is something that
we're gonna do and this is okay
it was always something that just ended
up happening
and then it was like oh god it's like
what just can't keep happening but more
let's put more rules in place how that
happened how bad did you feel i didn't
that was chafing i mean it was like
again you got to be wearing the right
stuff yeah right i mean lots can go
wrong you probably injure yourself like
it's not record let me just say we do
not recommend i have dry humping i do
it's horrible it really is horrible it's
it is stupid wow it's actually pretty
amazing i mean the only thing you're
doing if you're if you're wearing like i
mean
i hadn't played
soccer in many years but i'd but i did
find my old umbrella shoes yeah um bros
might as well not even be there
that's that's if you're going to be um
slogan good for soccer also for dry
humping
good for soccer great for dry humping um
i was i'm i'm sure i was confessing that
to god because it was just it was a lack
of self-control but it was just you were
gonna get married we're gonna yeah it
was just let's get let's just get it
let's just get there let's just get to
marriage let's get it let's get it over
with let's get on with it this is
torturous i mean i remember lying there
alone in the weeks leading up to my
wedding night
and again
i've already stated on the record that
the best reason for me believing in the
existence of god is the vagina which yes
i know the vulva thank you for
correcting me those of you who did
i'm speaking colloquially colloquially i
can't say the word um
but i'm lying there in bed thinking
about the fact that i'm going to get to
experience
this
stuff that i've been thinking about my
entire life yeah
which first of all is just
one of the things that i you know i've
since thought about is just how much
like
pressure that puts on
jesse
to be like because again i had not i had
not
communicated with um
candor the level of struggle and the
level of intensity and the level of
desire that wasn't even something that i
really got into until after our
deconstruction to be honest with you
because i just didn't think that her
mind was ready to understand just how my
mind worked i was i was still ashamed
yeah i mean yeah i mean and i think it
bears talking about for a second that
like all of the teaching to split
sessions with guys being taught
one thing and like talking about the
intricacies of how not to masturbate and
then whatever the girls talked about in
terms of like protecting their heart and
protect and like being a lady and
waiting they had their own book
that was just about them
being these spiritual princesses i
didn't read the book i know christy did
we're just thinking about that lady and
waiting yes she's waiting and also
like keeping
guys from sin in the meantime but there
was this disconnect
but where
got girls got this impression that
guys were animals
but that if they could rise above that
they could be spiritual powerhouses and
leaders
um
but
it was
i think it was taught as a dichotomy you
can either be
in the flesh or you can be in the spirit
and you want a guy who is so devoted to
god that he's that he's not
he's not addicted to porn or he's not
this and he's not that and all these
things that
you know
i guess my point is they i think
women could get this impression that
guys are either really holy or really
base
but we're actually we can actually be
both at the same time
and a lot of that stuff that
that it's like you got to protect them
from themselves because they're animals
and they they need to shed that skin
so to speak
it leaves this impression that like a
lot of thing a lot of these natural
desires that
that men have
and by the way women don't have them
question mark meaning as a woman you
shouldn't have them you're speaking from
the ideology not from from the ideology
it it leaves you it leaves women in a
place in this environment where they
might think that guys
you know they're either dogs or they're
or they've risen above it but there's
not something where they're actually
this is a natural part of who people are
men and women everybody
sexuality and desire and pleasure these
are not bad things that are innately
wrong
and
but the whole
but it's like holding guys to this high
standard that like you can't you can't
it doesn't give us as guys permission to
acknowledge
that
not only do we have struggles
but we have
we have desires
and and we have sensations and we have
things are happening
that are okay for us you know what i'm
trying to say i do
i like you felt like you couldn't talk
about certain things until after your
deconstruction about
like level of desire because it was
associated with sin and it took and it
takes a lot of time to deconstruct that
too that like the desire and sexuality
is still deconstructed yeah yeah and and
me too yeah
what i'm what i'm saying like if you
admit to a little something to your
partner if you've both been very holy
it's like this extreme shock
it's an extreme shock right and i think
that
we had been taught that like the
assumption
for all the guys is that of course
you're being tempted to look at porn of
course you're being tempted to
masturbate because those are the natural
desires of a man
the women were not getting those talks
because the assumption in baked into the
ideology is that the sexual desire is
really not coming from the woman
she's not she doesn't want it as much
you know and so
i don't think that's true i'm just
saying that that's kind of what was
baked into it that's why they weren't
talking about masturbation well what's
true is you cannot make a blanket
statement about that period well
christians
at least where we come from that's what
you did you put everybody into a room
and said you're all this way and we're
going to talk to you as if you're one
unit
yeah
and just ignore any sort of complicating
things that don't fit this binary but
what i'm really getting to is the fact
that
it sets up the wedding night yes to be
this thing where a consummation a
culmination well specifically the man is
doing something to the woman do you know
what i'm saying like this man has all
this pent up
stuff it isn't that the woman doesn't
have desire but it's just like
the man finally gets to do
sex to the woman i'm not saying i was
thinking that specifically or and i
definitely wasn't stating that and as
we'll talk about i mean the wedding
night and the our sexual relationship in
marriage just don't give it away you
don't give it away but
what i'm getting at is the fact that
like all the
stuff that had been put on into my brain
going into this situation was like i'm
finally getting to do this thing that
i've been freaking thinking about all my
life
and it was so strong and so intense
that it gets to a place where
almost unintentionally i'm expecting
jessie to serve this particular role of
being the person that i get to have sex
with does that make sense
which puts this incredible pressure on
someone versus it being this like
this is our relationship
being consummated and this is us both
kind of having our desires fulfilled
which we'll talk all about that in the
next episode but
going in with this idea that like i got
this overwhelming desire that i finally
get to unleash on this woman like it's
kind of a sick way to think about it do
you know what i'm saying and it wasn't a
conscious thing it was the subconscious
all the stuff that had been put on me
that i was bringing into that situation
i think that it is a reason why
you know we joke out here
like how old are you guys how old are
your kids you got a kid going off to
college what at your age is that it was
like we were on the north carolina
timeline really we're talking about this
like specifically it's i mean it is it's
not just a a bible belt
evangelical thing but it very much
was that as well
you know
this
this pent-up desire accelerates
uh getting married
it just does
because
you you get to a point where you just
you gotta you gotta unload man it's what
it it
that drive was not by any means the only
drive to get married but it it became
it was a factor if you're if you're a
christian if you're evangelical
christian and you subscribe to the idea
that sex can only be had in the context
of marriage
then and you want sex the person you're
gonna want marriage but the person that
you are dating
when you graduate from college
there is a very very high statistic
statistically speaking chance that
you're going to marry that person
because of circumstance now we got lucky
we got real lucky some of our close
friends got real lucky still they
married the right people they're in
great marriages but a lot of people
because it's so circumstantial
get into that marriage and then realize
that oh we got into this marriage
because of all the circumstances that
were driving us to get married not
because i knew what i wanted in a person
do you know what i'm saying like and so
yeah that's what says
we just one thing this little
treacherous dodge that ball oh hell yeah
we did another thing is
were there other people
in our in our friend group or in the
movement that were more devout than we
were i believe that there were i did we
didn't we weren't close with them but i
believe they were certainly out there
there were people in all across the
purity movement there are definitely
people who didn't have any physical
contact before they got married
and
you know we're gonna tell our story of
uh
losing our virginity
which is not a thing but we're gonna
tell the story of that not a thing
of first time we had sex on our wedding
night we're going to bring our wives in
we're going to let them call in we're
going to let them
we're going to we're going to lead them
we're going to calling in we're going to
invite christy and jesse to call and and
and weigh in on that topic and some
other topics
um we got to figure out exactly what
those are but i don't
and i don't want to give too much away
about that
but the fact that like
we did we did have a physical
relationship
that kind of ramped up into it
had an impact on our experience a
positive impact on our experience and
i've heard enough stories and i did that
people who were just like completely
locked off like virtual chastity belt
everywhere like no physical contact
until marriage and it's like there i
mean it could really
blow up in your face well on your
wedding night again i'm not speaking
from experience but i'm speaking from
anecdotal evidence here
uh
there it is not uncommon it is not
uncommon for
uh people in sort of a purity movement
who actually
are closeted gay and they don't that are
or they don't even know that they're gay
who
see
the purity movement and the way that
it's approached and then not having to
have physical contact with this person
of the opposite sex who you are quote
unquote supposed to marry yeah as a as a
sort of a salvation and they also see
that person as a potentially salvation
out of this thing that they're kind of
that is really tamped down and then or
it may just become it may be
false confirmation that they're super
straight and that they're super pure
right yeah what i'm getting at is there
is a phenomenon that is not uncommon for
someone who is actually gay and he's
either not dealt with it and not
realized it yet because it's been so
suppressed because of the culture that
they're in in in like a really
conservative culture
that they get into they there's there's
a salvation in a purity
obsessed
relationship because they're like i'm
actually not attracted to this person
but i'm confusing that with just the
ability to remain pure and then
having no physical contact because of
quote unquote being pure they get
married and then very quickly realize oh
i'm actually gay
and then those marriages of course
either you know they fall apart or yeah
so it's like again i've seen that happen
quite a bit actually and so it's um
just one of the pitfalls of being like
we're not going to have there's no
physical relationship at all up until
the point of marriage well you you're
highlighting
i mean
it
you could describe
our stories in this episode as
stunted development sexually i mean yeah
i could see how you might have that
perspective
um
just not understanding yourself and what
like
if if you were never given permission
whether you're a guy or girl or whatever
to to masturbate
then you're and and you never did
then you really there's a whole world
of yourself that you do not understand
that then you don't and and that's
that's
disempowering
when you don't when you when you're not
in control of your of your of your own
body
and your own pleasure that when you
don't have that autonomy and you don't
have that understanding
it's a it's a it's a it's an aspect of
personal development
that
could be could be stunted
and then you're playing catch-up you
know it's it's different than being a
late bloomer
than being a totally
suppressing
um
a natural beautiful aspect of
being human yeah and it can have
extremely damaging ripple effects in in
your relationships and and again i think
the the thing that may get missed as we
as we talk about this just because it's
not our experience is that
um as you'll see while there is baggage
and there are things that we've dealt
with and there are these negative
repercussions
in large part we dodged a lot of the
pitfalls of purity culture that's not an
endorsement of it
again if you
subscribe to thinking of this way then
you could use us and our particular
cases as a support for your argument
we're not here
we're not we're that's not what we're
doing we're telling our story but i
think that specifically with what you're
talking about right now with this whole
not getting comfortable with your own
body
again is something that the burden falls
so heavily on the women in the christian
world or the conservative evangelical
christian world because
and again this may have changed
somewhat i haven't been in that world
for a long time now so i don't know what
they're talking to college students
about in crew for instance it's been 20
years since they were doing it for us
more than 20 years so but at the time
what was happening is
talk we're not talking about
masturbation we're not talking about
porn with women and so you've got a
bunch of women who
their view of their own sexual
empowerment and understanding their own
body they bring it into the marriage and
they're coming into the marriage with
this thought of like oh my job is to
serve and pleasure my husband the
husband is coming into the marriage
thinking my job i'm the one who's really
sex obsessed and you know and even the
books that are written about it and the
talks that are given it's just like it
sets up this dichotomy where the men are
the ones who are really horny want to
have sex and then women are the ones who
let the men have sex when they want to
when they're not tired or whatever
and talk about stunting think about all
the women
we were obviously stunted but think
about the women who have been stunted in
not being able or being free to explore
their own sexuality and for and and
which is
is you know i think even more complex
for a woman than it is for a man in some
ways but yet it's like you i mean you
said one of the first things you said in
episode one was you just
out of context just said female orgasm
but
we'll talk about female orgasms in the
next episode but i think that that oh we
may even have one
but i think that that's the perfect
example of like
you know okay
you know
spoiler alert
there was one orgasm on my wedding night
and it wasn't a female one
[Laughter]
all right
you want to come back next episode well
there was more than one actually but
they were all from me
[Laughter]
yeah we're gonna
i think i'm looking forward to the next
conversation in the meantime uh
you got a wreck for him i do again a
completely out of context left turn
wreck um i have discovered recently
that my favorite type of fiction is
near-term post-apocalyptic fiction that
follows one protagonist
who usually has a dog
uh a big fan of a book called the dog
stars
um
i can't remember who wrote that peter
something but that's not what i'm
recommending so it doesn't matter i
found come on you got it okay
you can't double it up the dog's against
the rules but the one that i'm really
recommending and when i it's funny
because i realized that i like this
genre and then i found a book called a
boy and his dog at the end of the world
and i was like this is got it all there
you go this has got it all i mean it's
about a boy with a dog and this is the
end of the world
it's a it's by uh what's his name ca
fletcher he actually wrote this as well
ca fletcher there's charlie fletcher
this is like a prolific writer
screenwriter know nothing about him i
just know that i really like uh this
book and titles are very explanatory
at least this one is a boy and his dog
at the end of the world if you're into
you know the stuff that i'm listening to
it
um
yeah i'm a listener how's the narration
it's good it's good
good all right it's good it's good
air biscuits if you have any sex
questions
go ahead and let us have it for episode
after next
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best